- [Narrator] Principles for Success:
an Ultra Mini-Series Adventure
in 30 minutes and in 8 episodes.
Episode 6, Your Two Biggest Barriers.
I can't tell you which path
in life is best for you
because I don't know how important it is
for you to achieve big goals
relative to how important it is
for you to avoid the pains
required to get them.
This is the courage I spoke of earlier
and we each have to feel these
things out for ourselves.
After my big mistake in
calling for a depression,
I had come to one of life's
forks in the road as we all do.
If I made the choice to take
a normal job and play it safe,
I would have ended up with
a very different life than the one I had.
But as long as I can pay the
rent, put food on the table,
and educate my kids, the only
choice for me was to risk
crossing the jungle in pursuit
of the best life possible.
My big mistake in betting on a depression
gave me a healthy fear of being wrong,
in other words, it gave me deep humility,
which was exactly what I needed.
At the same time, it didn't stop me
from aggressively going
after the things I wanted.
To succeed, I needed to see
more than I alone can see.
But standing in my way of doing that
were the two biggest
barriers everyone faces:
our ego and blind spot barriers.
These barriers exist because
of how our brains work.
First, let's explore the ego barrier.
When I refer to your ego barrier,
I'm talking about the parts
of your brain that prevent you
from acknowledging your
weaknesses objectively
so that you can figure
out how to deal with it.
Your deepest-seated needs
and fears reside in areas
of your brain that control
your emotions and are not
accessible to your higher
level conscious awareness
and because our need to be
right can be more important
than our need to find out what's true,
we like to believe our own opinions
without properly stress testing them.
We especially don't like to look
at our mistakes and weaknesses.
We are instinctively prone to react
to explorations of them
as though they're attacks.
We get angry, even though
it would be more logical
for us to be open to feedback from others.
This leads to our making
inferior decisions,
learning less, and falling
short of our potentials.
The second is the blind spot barrier.
Everyone has blind spots.
The blind spot barrier
is when a person believes
he or she can see everything,
but it's a simple fact
that no one alone can see a
complete picture of reality.
Naturally people can't
appreciate what they can't see,
just as we all have
different ranges for singing,
hearing pitch, and seeing colors, we have
different ranges for seeing
and understanding things.
For example, while some people are better
at seeing the big picture,
others excel at seeing details.
Some are linear thinkers
and others are more lateral.
While some are creative but not reliable,
others are reliable but
not creative, and so on.
Because of how our brains
are wired differently,
everyone perceives the world
around them differently.
By doing what comes naturally to us,
we fail to account for our
weaknesses and we crash.
Either we keep doing that or we change.
Aristotle defined tragedy
as a terrible outcome
arising from a person's fatal flaw.
A flaw that, had it been fixed,
would have instead led
to a wonderful outcome.
In my opinion, these two
barriers are the main impediments
that get in the way of
good decision-making.
My fear of being wrong gave
me the radical open-mindedness
I needed and that changed everything.